uh I have a Sports Nutrition business or
supplement supplement business that's
that's Kevin Gates would would was
speaking about your Ambrosia pre-workout
yeah yeah he's with us honest that's
that's my spiritual brother right there
shout out to Kev yeah
um so yeah so I got Ambrosia we got the
number one plant-based protein in the
country it's crazy
uh I have a healthy snack company called
snack House Foods
um I own a chunk of uh one of the most
successful meal prep delivery companies
called Trifecta wow killing it going
public soon
uh shout out to Greg
um yeah and I got like things I do on
the digital side like um I have an app
for online training and challenges
YouTube channel is great YouTube is
popping you know I love YouTube man
that's that's that really was a catalyst
for Success across all my businesses yes
YouTube yeah I feel like you are very
consistent with the I feel like you know
people do workout videos and obviously
you do interviews you do just
motivational [ __ ] but even just your
workout videos are a lot more palatable
than like
some of the like typical YouTube [ __ ]
you'd see that makes sense they're like
more aesthetically like I could watch
this and like you know why because
you're a hip-hop dude right right I'm A
hip-hop dude so you know people won't
realize why they was liking my videos
but it was like I used to rap right and
the same people that was doing my Beats
and my videos back then were doing my
Beats and videos for the fitness stuff